لعده ساعات حاصرت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عده منازل هنا في قريه صير
جنوبي جنين اليات عسكريه دخلت تباعا وقامت
بمحاوله اخذ عدد من الفلسطينيين كدروع
بشريه وحاصرت عده منازل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اطلقت النار بشكل عشوائي على
عدد من المنازل التي قامت بمحاصرتها من
بينها هذا ال منزل الذي يعود لعائله ابو
الرب قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتهم
العائله باخفاء ابنها المطارد حجزو ولا خ
كلف شونا بعدين انا قلت له يعني حلني اذا
سمحت واجا ضابط المخابرات سالني قلت له
انا ما شفت مصطفى اطلاقا وبعرف وينه من
شهر ونص هددوك بشي قاللي بدي اقتت له يجيك
حي طيب ولا ولا ميت قلت له انا بفضل يجيني
حي على جري يمشي قال لي لازم احنا نعمل
طريقه انه هو يسلم حاله شكرا لكح بالطبع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عاثت فسادا في
عدد من المنازل من بينها
منزل الشاب مصطفى ابو الروب بعد احتجاز
العائله كما
راينا تم اطلاق النار بشكل عشوائي هذه بعض
اثار طلقات النار التي اطلقها جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سواء من خارج ال منزل
او من داخله كما نرى هنا في اسقف هذه
الغرف الرصاص الذي اطلقه جنود الاحتلال
على منزل عائله ابو الرب هذه المشاهد
تتكرر في كل يوم وفي كل ليله في كل انحاء
الضفه الغربيه مجرد عمليه اعتقال قد تتحول
الى ماساه وذلك منذ السابع من اكتوبر جفال
بديري الجزيره من قريه صير janu jinin